cette affaire des sans-papiers dure
depuis maintenant cinq mois elle a
commencé par l'occupation de l'église
saint-ambroise le récit valérie gâcher
les sans papiers de st bernard ou
d'abord été ceux de saint-ambroise c'est
en effet avec l'occupation de cette
église du 11e arrondissement à paris que
leur mouvement a commencé le 18 mars
dernier né dans les foyers de
travailleurs immigrés l'idée d'une
action collective débouchera sur cinq
mois d'errance le 22 mars l'église
saint-ambroise et évacués par les crs à
la demande du furet une polémique s'en
suit concernant le rôle joué par la
hiérarchie catholique
les africains trouve alors refuge dans
le gymnase japy situé à proximité
mais deux jours plus tard nouvelle
intervention policière
cinquante deux maliens sont alors
reconduit par avion dans leur pays
le 29 mars le théâtre du soleil
accueille les sans papiers à la
cartoucherie de vincennes
onze jours de répit puis ils repartent
des entrepôts vides de la sncf dans le
18e arrondissement leur servent d'abris
temporaires
le mouvement semble alors s'essouffler
mais dit les relancer le 24 juin par une
quarantaine de femmes qui envahissent le
hall de la mairie du xviiie
deux jours plus tard dans la plus grande
discrétion les autorités régularisent la
situation de 20 de ses africains
notamment celle d'un déboutés du droit
d'asile
cette avancée at elle remet au tibet les
sans-papiers toujours est il que deux
jours plus tard le 28 juin
ils décident d'envahir l'église saint
bernard le conflit prend alors un tour
plus politique face aux partis de gauche
pour une fois unis la majorité semble se
diviser hier ma déclaration d'alain
juppé a mis fin aux espoirs de nombreux
africains commencé dans une église il ya
cinq mois
leur lutte s'est achevée ce matin dans
une autre
et cette affaire provoque
divisions au sein même de la majorité si
l'opposition elle se retrouve unies pour
appeler jacques chirac à la négociation
l'initiative de gilles de robien à
droite ne fait pas l'unanimité y compris
dans son propre parti et roland sicard
et philippe deslandes les sans papiers
ne voulait pas manquer le rendez-vous un
entretien dans un palais officiels il le
souhaitait depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
l'impatience était telle qu'ils étaient
un peu en avance d'accord qu'on va pas
ouvrir la porte
il faut dire que si à gauche tout le
monde est d'accord pour réclamer une
négociation dans la majorité gilles de
robien est l'un des premiers à faire un
geste
résultat une heure et quart d'entretien
et à la sortie le constat d'une
situation difficile
j'ai ce sentiment aujourd'hui que ils
sont demandeurs de dialogue qu'il
comprenne la complexité de la situation
au regard de la loi française qui le
perçoit bien que la situation de tous
dans l'église n'est pas identique et que
des solutions moduler et au cas par cas
sont sont à rechercher seulement gilles
de robien par est isolé à l'udf certains
critiques quant au rpr et au
gouvernement ils font bloc autour de
jean louis debré jean louis debré il a
le devoir impérieux de faire ce que l'on
attend lui c'est à dire son travail de
ministre
donc je ne soutiens tout à fait puis je
crois qu'il ne faut pas se laisser
déborder par ceux qui en mal de cause
ont décidé d'utiliser ces pauvres sans
papiers comme une chair à canon
politique
il y a eu une majorité de députés et de
sénateurs qui ont voté des lois
ces lois s'appliquent le gouvernement ne
peut pas transgresser à cela ou alors il
n'est plus digne de ce nom
en tout cas la réception des
sans-papiers à l'assemblée montre bien
que la sphère se déplace sur le terrain
politique entre une gauche qui mobilise
et une majorité qui se divise le
gouvernement doit trouver une solution
au lendemain de l'interview
juppé les forces de l'ordre sont donc
intervenus ce matin à l'église saint
bernard
environ un millier de gendarmes mobiles
et de crs qui ont forcé vers 19h45 la
porte de l'église savoir saint bernard
pour s'emparer des sans papiers alors
50e jour de grève de la faim les
grévistes ont été évacués vers des
hôpitaux militaires
les autres ont pris la direction du
centre de rétention de vincennes où leur
cas devrait être examiné le récit de
cette matinée musclée pascal douce est
bon et valérie fournier jusqu'au bout
ils tentent de faire barrage à l'assaut
des forces de l'ordre eux qui campe avec
les réfugiés depuis des semaines font un
rempart de leurs corps
esquive les couvre gêne leur progression
mais les gendarmes mobiles arriveront à
leurs fins en 20 minutes
les portes de l'église mettront moins de
temps à résister pendant ce temps à
l'intérieur une barricade de chaises et
ériger à la hâte
elle ne tiendra que quelques minutes
8h15 les gendarmes mobiles entre
simultanément par les deux portes le
curé doit interrompre la célébration
qu'il dirigeait est-ce que vous
ressentez actuellement je viens j'ai
pleuré
j'ai un peu honte sur vous pour nous
l'issue est désormais certaine alors les
nerfs lâchent à boubacar diop délégués
des familles doit calmer ses troupes
mais comme les autres il refuse de
bouger alors l'évacuation prend un tour
plus musclée à moins de 100 mètres de là
des paris vient d'autres venus de plus
loin et des habitants du quartier à
courre tentent de rejoindre ceux qui
sont à l'intérieur et les gendarmes
mobiles lance des gaz lacrymogènes pour
les repousser
au pied de l'église ceux qui ont dormi
là et qui résistent encore aux forces de
l'ordre leur font signe de venir
pendant ce temps l'évacuation des dix
grévistes de la faim se fait par la
petite porte du presbytère
ils sont dirigés vers les hôpitaux
militaires bégin et persil le professeur
choix de solberg lui sera déloger de
force
contraints d'attendre ici tandis que les
parisiens continuent d'affluer a clamé
leur solidarité
j'ai vu passer les enfants dans l'est
car on a quand même les larmes aux yeux
en voyant ça moi je suis pas fier d'être
français
nous reviendrons sur scène
allez qui ont attendu la radio
javier martinez
on arrive à mu plus tard très vite la
mobilisation s'organise au même moment
devant l'entrée principale
les sans papiers sont emmenés un parent
vers les bus dans le calme mais non sans
appréhension
les familles ont peur d'être séparés
madjiguène cissé porte parole des sans
papiers refuse de monter sans son mari
et son enfant
quant à emmanuelle béart et les
conduites avec d'autres sympathisants
vers le commissariat le plus proche
les onze bus vont partir les uns après
les autres vers le centre de rétention
de vincennes
l'opération aura duré trois heures
et sitôt les opérations
minet jean louis debré le ministre de
l'intérieur a réuni la presse place
beauvau pour expliquer le choix du
gouvernement
le moment était venu d'appliquer la loi
avec fermeté mais avec le souci
d'humanité et de coeur que souhaite le
gouvernement
que va-t-il se passer maintenant
pour la première catégorie celle des
régularisables ils recevront un titre de
séjour et ceci dès la semaine prochaine
pour les personnes de la 2e et 3e
catégories et qui ne sont pas
régularisable et pour lesquels il existe
dès maintenant des arrêtés de reconduite
exécutoire cette reconduite sera mise en
oeuvre pour les autres c'est à dire pour
ceux qui ne sont pas régularisable mais
pour qui les procédures ne permette pas
encore aujourd'hui de leur imposer de
quitter le territoire national
ces procédures seront conduites à leur
terme et ils devront quitter notre pays
tôt ou tard
emmanuelle béart bon soin
vous êtes beaucoup investi dans ce
mouvement des sans-papiers de saint
bernard en partageant les jours et des
nuits avec eux et en vivant cette cette
opération d'évacuation jusqu'à la fin ce
matin ce soit vous êtes vous êtes déçu
vous voyez choqué en voyant ces images
d'abord je voudrais dire que je ne suis
pas là en tant que comédienne mais en
tant que femme mère de deux enfants
j'aimerais son j'ai le sentiment que si
je ne témoigne pas de ce que j'ai vu ce
matin je ne pourrai plus ni vivres ni
dormir en paix donc voilà je suis là
pour ça ce que nous avons montré ce que
vous avez montré à la télé je dirais que
c'est peut-être bien loin de là de la
souffrance de tous les enfants avec qui
je suis resté jusqu'au bout avec qui
nous sommes restés jusqu'au bout
je voudrais aussi ajouter que sur
certaines images on ne voit pas qu'il y
a eu plusieurs viols notamment une
église dont les portes ont été détruites
à coups de hache des vitraux cassés des
enfants moi pour ma part j'avais un
petit enfant parce que les enfants
s'accrocher à nous en essayant de
comprendre dans une sorte de terreur des
larmes de créer un petit enfant sur mes
genoux qui a fait pipi tellement il
avait peur qu'ils retrouvent et ni son
père ni sa mère
tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai j'ai
beaucoup de mal à parler parce que c'est
encore très récent et de revoir toutes
les images
ce soir c'est très difficile pour moi
j'ai trouvé cette opération très
violente plus part je dirais moralement
moralement extrêmement violente on a
pour moi violer la dignité de ces gens
ces gens ont été traqués et red endroit
d'église en gymnase pendant des mois et
des mois je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
a laissé pourrir la situation s'il
fallait étudier au cas par cas au cas
par cas pourquoi ne l'at-on pas fait
avant pourquoi est-ce qu'on a laissé ses
enfants ces femmes ces hommes
célibataires ces grévistes de la faim
aller aussi loin
je suis indigné révolté mais j'ai
surtout mal j'ai surtout mal pas pour
moi qui a été arrêté pendant 2
zéro commissariat et qui a été relâchée
extrêmement vite mais je pense à ce soir
voilà donc de les revoir là tous dans la
mesure où les sans papiers ne naît pas
vouloir l'air de vouloir accepter une
négociation qui a parker noah hier soir
j'étais dans l'église on a pendant cinq
mois ces gens ont demandé à être
entendus
on la refuse absolument tout dialogue le
gouvernement
je tiens à préciser que je ne suis
d'aucun parti politique
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à mettre
votre image aux personnalités
j'ai débarqué un jour j'ai débarqué il
ya quelques temps tout simplement parce
l'hilarité humaine avec des couches du
lait je suis moi ma mère de deux enfants
j'ai eu l'impression qu'il était
important d'y aller et d'aider je savais
que les familles commencent à manquer de
produits de base de choses essentielles
et donc j'ai débarqué là comme ça et
puis je suis resté parce que j'ai eu un
sentiment d'injustice
on a répété pendant des mois qu'il
s'agissait de clandestins j'ai donc
appris en volant et en parlant avec tous
les gens qui étaient autour de moi les
délégués africains qu'il s'agissait de
jean louis oncle édité en clandestinité
par les doigts parce que c'est à dire
que je n'ai rencontré que des gens qui
ont travaillé en france qui ont une
famille ou qui sont célibataires mais
les stigmates r c'est pas parce qu'on
s'est pas reproduit qu'on n'a pas le
droit qu'on n'a pas le même droit que
les autres
je n'ai rencontré que des gens qui ont
essayé de former une famille de forme et
de ce2 de vivre ici où la vie est dure
mais possible dans leur pays on souffre
moi je viens de mauritanie les gens
crèvent là-bas en mali les gens crèvent
aussi je peux vous dire si vous espériez
une autre attitude une autre issue à ce
une autre attitude du gouvernement de
réviser ce que j'ai vu ce matin je ne
l'oublierai jamais mais c'est pas très
grave
ce que les enfants ont vu ce matin ils
n'oublieront non plus c'est très grave
ils n'enverront pas non plus c'est très
grave
le commentaire du
dina lustiger fallait-il sacrifier 300
africains pour obtenir enfin un débat
sur une question aussi fondamentale que
l'immigration les autres réactions de
gauche et de droite
recueilli par françoise david les gilles
de blair on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement a manqué la tan évident
savoir vivre qui aurait été la marque
d'un savoir faire sur un dossier
difficile et dans ces conditions on est
submergé par une vraie émotion et en
même temps on se dit que cette
intervention de forces ne règle rien que
va-t-il se passer maintenant
comment vont se régler les situations de
ces familles qui étaient sans papiers à
la suite des lois pasqua le gouvernement
en prenant une décision choquante mais
en plus rien réglé cette intervention se
situe bien dans dans l'esprit de la
vieille droite brutale et cynique il
faut bien dire pour des calculs
politiciens sordide
cela démontre encore là l'incapacité du
gouvernement à régler les problèmes de
régler ces questions humaines à être
sourd à à l'opinion publique
hier le premier ministre après avoir
consulté le conseil d'état a dit la loi
et a dit qu'il était prêt à aller au
delà d'une lecture rigide de la loi qui
était prêt à examiner les cas
individuels
c'est ce que réclamaient les personnes
de saint bernard
j'espérais que fier soirs où tout au
long de la nuit un petit geste qui se
manifeste du côté des sans papiers pour
dire et bien là il ya quand même
l'amorcé d'un dialogue et avec l'amorcé
d'un dialogue on peut espérer une issue
qui soit autre que celle de ce matin
je crois que dans cette affaire le
gouvernement appliquer la mission qui
est la sienne qui est d'appliquer la loi
nous étions arrivés à une phase de
rapport de force extrêmement tendue
malgré les ouvertures qui avait été fait
et je crois qu'à ce stade même si chacun
peut le regretter
il fallait que les règles de l'état de
droit soit respecté jusqu'au bout
madame monsieur bonsoir
les africains de saint-bernard quittent
le territoire français quatre d'entre
eux ont été conduits sur la base
militaire d'evreux en compagnie de
cinquante trois autres immigrés en
situation irrégulière
là bas un airbus a310 de l'armée de
l'air les attendait il a décollé à 19
heures c'est ce que confirme ce soir le
ministère de l'intérieur sur place à
evreux nous allons trouver d'ici
quelques instants marie pierre farkas
marie-pierre vous êtes donc sur place il
ya eu semble-t-il quelques heurts entre
manifestants et policiers avant le
départ de cet avion
oui là vous voyez une base des requêtes
une base arrière très calme comme elle
est d'habitude puisque en général ils
s'opposent qu un transall par jour en
revanche on va faire un petit retour en
images pour voir ce qui s'est passé dans
l'après midi et vous allez voir que la
l'atmosphère était un petit peu plus
tendue aux alentours de 15h30 des
véhicules se sont placés sur le terrain
où commencer à entrer en mouvement des
véhicules militaires
et puis vous allez le voir sur cette
image tout à fait au fond juste après
cette image des policiers qui sont en
faction
vous voyez l'autocar l'autocar à
l'intérieur desquels étaient les les
sans-papiers et on nous confirme ici
aussi le qu'ils étaient 57 à bord 14
malien les autres étant à irois et
sénégalais vous voyez qu ensuite les
images étaient impossibles à tourner
tous les véhicules militaires s'étaient
mis devant exactement au même moment aux
alentours de 17h15 devant la base
aérienne il y avait une manifestation
qui était jusqu'ici très calme uni avec
150 personnes mais à 17h15 les policiers
ont eu ordre d'intervenir et ça s'est
passé de façon très musclée avec des
gens qui étaient plutôt pacifiste et les
policiers sont intervenus pendant un bon
quart d'heure il y a eu on dénombre ce
soir trois ou quatre blessés légers
en revanche vous allez voir l'aca c'est
la période où les affrontements étaient
les plus violents
en revanche le maire adjoint de gayant a
été blessé c'est lui que vous voyez au
sol en ce moment marie-pierre donc je me
confirmer il ya donc eu un avion qui est
partie d'evreux et pour l'instant c'est
tout il n'y a pas d'autre vol en
préparation pas du tout c'est un airbus
a310 qui d'habitude sert transport de
troupes qui a fait beaucoup de rotations
sur la bosnie et les seules informations
que nous avons ici proviennent du
président du comité de soutien des sans
papiers
pour les autres sans papiers
cuillère de l'église saint-bernard les
procédures administratives et
judiciaires se sont poursuivies toute la
journée dans toute leur complexité
certains notamment les femmes et les
enfants ont été libérés dans la nuit du
centre de rétention de vincennes pour le
d'autres les auditions ont commencé au
palais de justice de paris l'une des
porte parole des sans papiers a été
condamné à deux mois de prison avec
sursis alors que le procureur avait
requis trois mois de prison ferme et
trois ans d'interdiction de territoire
le point avec valérie fourni et gilles
marini scènes de vie quotidienne au
centre de rétention de vincennes des
immigrés arrive menotté mais difficile
aujourd'hui de savoir si parmi eux se
trouvaient les expulser de saint bernard
dans cette confusion qui a régné toute
la journée on repère tout d'un coup des
cars transportant des africains
destination inconnue en revanche au
palais de justice
quelques certitudes ce matin 34 100
papillon vu leur garde à vue renouvelée
dont les dix grévistes de la faim et au
sujet de deux d'entre eux leur avocate
est inquiète
ils ne sont plus à l'hôpital contrôle et
de la gravité de la situation et
prennent une mesure de mise en liberté
deux
de ce barça web autre sujet de
mécontentement des avocats il estime
n'avoir pu rencontrer leur client placé
hier en rétention administrative dans
des conditions normales ça ne peut pas
voir chacun cinq clients les voyons tous
ensemble nous n'avons pas pu pénétrer
dans les box qui sont habituellement
réservé aux avocats à 10 heures cet
après midi une soixantaine de personnes
sont venues soutenir 46 autres sans
papiers qui comparaissent actuellement
devant le tribunal de grande instance de
paris
et pour les avocats c'est également la
confusion il nous manque un certain
nombre de sans papiers actuellement on
en a recensé un peu plus de 60
nécessairement y en ad'autres ailleurs
environ quinze autres sont papiers sont
actuellement devant la 23e chambre
correctionnelle
et parmi eux il y a à boubacar diop leur
porte parole le préfet semble t'il
retirerait sa requête sur la
prolongation rétention conséquence il
devrait être remis en liberté ce n'est
pas certain madigan fils et autres porte
parole des sans papiers est condamné à
deux mois de prison avec sursis
elle vient d'être remise en liberté
dernière certitude les 53 femmes et 64
enfants de l'église saint-bernard ont
été relâchés hier soir et déposer à leur
demande devant une station de métro
nous ne sommes pas des clandestins
la balade des sans papiers sur un air de
reggae a rythmé le cortège de république
à la ville est ce qu'il y a là des sans
papiers de 24 nationalités tous
regroupés autour du leader du mouvement
de saint bernard
ils sont pas sans papiers parce qu'il
l'aurait voulu mais parce que c'est la
loi depuis l'évacuation de l'église
saint-bernard afflux de 30 collectifs de
sans-papiers se sont créés et
aujourd'hui étaient présents même ceux
qui ne font jamais parler d'eux les
chinois ils n'ont pas d'habitude à se
manifester dans la rue
cette fois on a en a plus de choix si
nous voulons on doit vivre il faut quand
le manifeste
ils réclament tous l'abrogation des lois
pasqua et la régularisation de tous les
sans papiers comme le frère de l'église
saint bernard
toujours fidèle
sensibiliser aussi le fini au public et
particulièrement
l'église voit les verts
ses ouailles échofête différents
d'inspiration
si intransigeant moi je dis attention
je sais qu'il ya des échéances
électorales je sais qu'il ya une
pression du front national mais en tout
état de cause il faut pas prendre les
yeux écrit un otage et la mobilisation
autour des sans papiers ne s'est pas
essoufflé entre 11 et 15 mille personnes
ont répondu à nouveau à leurs appels en
manifestant aujourd'hui leur soutien
ils sont encore une vingtaine au sort
incertain membres du troisième collectif
des sans-papiers appréhendé mardi lors
d'un coup de force contre le centre
d'accueil des étrangers
dix personnes d'origine chinoise sont
toujours en rétention et seront jugés en
appel samedi matin depuis hier soir les
trois quarts du groupe défilent devant
le juge délégué en vue d'une reconduite
à la frontière pour vice de forme
quatre ont déjà été relaxé concernant
huit autres personnes d'origine kurde de
son passé en correctionnelle et ont fait
appel
les autres restent toujours en garde à
vue prolongée à la disposition de la
huitième section du parquet des
différences de traitement énoncés par la
défense c'est le soin l'inorganisation
des services de la préfecture soit la
volonté délibérée de finalement de
diviser une certaine défense qui s'est
mis en place pour les sans papiers pour
simplifier en plus des procédures
d'appel samedi le tribunal administratif
se prononcera sur les recours d'arrêt de
reconduite à la frontière
nous avons voulu savoir ce qu'étaient
devenus certains de ces sans papiers
l'exemple de ces personnes l'une a été
régularisée notre pas emilie lançant luc
bachofen mabhouh est une ancienne de
saint bernard
elle a été régularisée il y a deux ans
juste après l'évacuation de l'église
à 22 ans mais bouffé des ménages et son
mari tient la plonge dans un restaurant
tout dans les fiches de paye et leurs
enfants vont à l'école
ils vivent à quatre dans une même pièce
ici dans un immeuble du 10e
arrondissement occupé depuis un an par
le collectif saint bernard si tout n'est
pas facile
avoir des papiers a changé leur vie ça à
5 beaucoup de sauce même on peut se
promener
ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils savent ça
parce que ici toulalan de racketter par
ces salaires pas pire kidman moment même
où puisque les enfants de quoi ils
démarraient la papier
si tu n'as pas les papiers des enfants
il va parler à l'écran sur les 300
sans-papiers qui avait investi
saint-bernard 17 n'ont pas été
régularisée biagui fait par type cela il
est frappé d'une interdiction territoire
et son dossier est l'un des plus
compliqués marié et père d'un enfant né
en france il a été expulsé au mali après
saint bernard oui mon esquissé ma femme
elle est restée là
mon 9 ans nationaux hésité là bas mais
les familles janv ier
on n'a pas eu ma femme
nabli ceux qui ont été régularisés comme
comme des aides les autres comme à
l'origine du mouvement le mot d'ordre
est des papiers pour tous on a toujours
haudiquet bombay temps qui reste un sans
papiers de saint bernard qui n'a pas été
régularisée la liste de saint-bernard ça
continue s'ils veulent que la lutte des
saint-bernard et paraître une idée là
ighilahriz tous les sans-papiers de
saint bernard scemama lors d'un plat on
n'en parle plus john day est une
offrande saint bernard elle est née le
17 août six jours avant l'expulsion de
l'église pour être française à l'âge de
13 ans elle devra faire une demande de
nationalité
l'église saint bernard à paris lieu de
rassemblement cet après midi d'un
millier de manifestants venus marquer le
deuxième anniversaire de l'évacuation
des sans-papiers
un anniversaire qui se veut le symbole
du combat pour une régularisation totale
des sans papiers emilie lançant josé
boulesteix deux ans après c'est tout
naturellement devant st bernard qui se
sont donnés rendez-vous une église dont
il porte jusque nom et qui pour la
plupart leur a permis de réaliser un
rêve avoir des papiers avoir déjà ne
connaissez pas mais maintenant tout le
monde
s'ils avaient pas un mouvement de
l'église
donc c'est grâce à toutes les dérives et
les sans papiers sont plusieurs
personnalités arlette laguiller
monseigneur gaillot sont venus une
nouvelle fois apporté leur soutien aux
sans papiers le nombreux anonymes des
voisins des collectifs de différentes
régions ont manifesté cet après midi
au total près d'un millier de personnes
ont ainsi défilé dans le quartier de la
goutte d'or pour madjiguène cissé porte
parole des saint-bernard
cet anniversaire est celui d'une
victoire après l'écossé debré la lutte
des sans-papiers continue nous arrivons
aujourd'hui à la régularisation de la
quasi totalité des membres de votre
collectif et nous sommes fiers
aujourd'hui d'avoir deux niveaux et
avaries et d'avoir gagné
l'exemple de saint bernard fait rêver
depuis deux ans plusieurs autres que
l'équipe de sans papiers se sont créés
dans toute la france plus de 60000
personnes demandent à être régularisés
les deux circulaires de cet été devrait
effectivement permettre à dix ou quinze
mille d'entre elles d'obtenir un titre
de séjour